[Music]
in seriously news
seriously dude submitted by aspiring Joe
Mallya resident mmm inspiring Lee
everybody on their just get in there
just doing this this is application
process oh I'm so uneducated in Joe my
user and going there yeah a mom was
arrested for taking away her daughter's
phone as punishment what serious oh my
god obviously that was like a light
punishment yeah wait so you can that's
almost like grounding her kid oh is it
because she stole her property oh you
nailed it oh and within the her property
so the debt okay so let me tell you the
whole easy right now you're telling me
if you beat your kids yeah do they knock
you slap my kids or [ __ ] but you still
can't slap your kids damn they're gonna
call like you can't get caught not in
the front end that's what you can do
that like if you like if you punch a kid
in the face ten thousand to call it
abuse pather you have to be like go all
the way through some [ __ ] not in the
fate I don't think you can in the face
what the cat Bruce they can't lose no
that's a they can't Bruce if they bruise
then it's abuse oh yeah Bruce echoes
abuse how are you supposed to beat your
kids legal either mm-hmm I don't just
beat them period you torture them dude
what play mine mentally taught yeah yeah
no that's mental abuse how do you Mike
type but they can't prove that how do
you Mike Tyson then legally I don't
think you can't are you taking on Mexico
that's a my mom would do yeah but when
you come back to America you could get
in trouble for what you did overseas
come to Mexico state Mexico or roses
popular country take them to Russia yeah
take it away run away I don't like this
so how do you train kids without beating
their asses I don't think you train them
I think I think you have to just be a
good parent okay
you're on that New Age stuff my mom used
to tell me go outside and you pick your
switch what does that mean
pick your switch like you get your
weapon you pick your to pick a twig or
whatever from outside 22
yeah so go to the room and pick your
belt yeah
and that was like that was the ultimate
learnings there was some psychological
she's got exact whirls though you don't
do that how you get moral I'm a
talkative pick is belt you know what
because it's for the child the
punishment is entirely in your hand one
you did this and two now you've got to
pick the whip and I'm going use to
punish you play dumb get games win dumb
prizes my parents never beat me with
things they just punched me in the head
[Laughter]
they were so moral to their life you
know other parents they beat their kids
with things we don't beat we don't beat
you with things and I'm like you still
beat me though that's so that that's
like that's some twisted [ __ ] right
there like like we're better than them
because we don't and it sucks is there's
two of them backing each other up yeah
they're like yeah we ended like you if I
can warm up their knuckles your parents
come at you with like as a unified front
like we had acid thrown us us so like
this isn't even yeah they thought they
were doing some that they thought that
was like the Millennial [ __ ] like you
know how like they're like well back in
my day you know this so they don't like
well we're doing something better
oh my god it's happening we're about to
start saying back in my day like we're
almost like legally obligated to start
saying back except you know what my mom
used to say so my mom used to use this
Chinese proverb on me and it was a under
the sky there has been no mothers that
have made mistakes I love that so she
said beat the [ __ ] out of me and she's
like and she goes any time you feel like
I've wronged you use your brain and
figure out how your mom is perfect for
what she that is I love it
[ __ ] [ __ ] me up and then and she's like
under the sky there has never been a
mother than
made a mistake ethanol I think she's
ever said oh I could help you with this
one it's pretty [ __ ] up but you dared
me but but she never made a mistake of
card in her all right well this mom got
arrested though yeah one did this bullsh
Chinese proverb all right so this excuse
me officer I'll probably hold up in
court
yeah under the sky there is no mother
that has ever made a mistake thousand
insane asylum alright so this mom was
punishing her 15 year-old daughter by
taking away her phone somehow her
ex-husband found out about this and call
the cops on his wife or his ex-wife
saying that she stole the phone because
it belonged to him so [ __ ] up I was a
little [ __ ] that child is not using the
kid to get back out the ex-wife yep
that's exactly what that puppy like
daddy said so my god that's so fun
uh-huh that's my [ __ ] oh yeah that song
also did they like the cops not realize
this was petty did they give her an
opportunity like all right so this went
all the way to court it was like a
five-month long thing so the mom got out
on bail and a two hundred dollar bail
five months that's ridicu this has been
dragged out for five months so finally
the prosecutors they added another
charge over the same alleged phone theft
which is larceny by conversion I don't
know why they did that but they did and
then minutes later after they added that
second charge the prosecutors they go to
the judge and they tell him that they
have discussed this case with the victim
in the case or at least the person that
they believed owned the property and
then it turns out that the dad wasn't
the owner of the of the property it was
the daughter so that means that the mom
was just being a parent and taking away
yeah
till all the charges were dropped but
it's like this point our judicial system
I know all those tax dollars boy you
know
yeah so then the court-appointed lawyer
for the defendant they were saying she
was like yeah you know it sucks like a
lot of the times these cases don't get
vetted out and somehow it led up all the
way up to this point but yeah that's
[ __ ] stupid so annoying like it's
totally the dad trying to get back in
his ex-wife like for sure like I'm like
the daughter calls dad crying and then
he was like I'm going to cure this and
called 9-1-1 like when I hear stories
like this I go that's why there's so
many crazy [ __ ] people it's like uh
can you imagine the the [ __ ] of
generational fuck-ups that went on
through both of these families to create
such a [ __ ] parent mm maybe like not
the mom but then like the dad the
pettiest dad there was a petty ass
caveman and one day you know I got
[ __ ] jealous because you know this
other caveman stole one of his shiny
stones or some [ __ ] he passed on his
pettiness genetics oh I feel like it is
petting it
the nonstops in the [ __ ] DNA it's
like every graduation I've had my
parents even though they're there for me
they have to sit on opposite sides of
the bench or the room or whatever and
I'm just like can it just be about me
for like the next two hours why is it
still while you still gotta like dog my
dad like every five seconds just can't
get rid of that Patti dude there's a lot
of people that are Patti man it's funny
because you could see it's a it's a
total lack of self control like they
can't be above it so they just let they
just get so bothered like a [ __ ] kid
man well they're you know that like the
the daughter like she definitely like
had some pole in with her dad does she
could have been like no don't do that to
mom I don't but you know thought it was
like yeah
teach her that you lesson so now she has
learned like in her brain like I can get
out of a tie I'm not I can't be punished
like that's basically people and get
what I want
yeah I can manipulate people against
each other oh that's so gross that's
when I believe in child abuse
what compadre
stopping by again the abuser not me I
don't hit kids best dad boys now don't
hit kid I don't hate kids
who's gonna because the parents are
petty then oh so how old is this girl 15
a 15 year old pro boxer amateur boxer
you know the punch that's a lady I was
same height everything so like a 15 year
old Ronda Rousey yeah mm that sounds
dangerous can you imagine if your
daughter was Ronda Rousey [ __ ] you want
I know I'm gonna start because a boxer
just starts beating your ass every day
man if that happens I would do crazy
[ __ ] like I would bite her [ __ ] pull
her hair you know I mean like I would I
would've do the like man-on-man [ __ ] cuz
it's if my daughter was Ronda Rousey and
we got into a fight like I'm breaking a
beer bottle over her head or something
you know yeah you should be given don't
mess with that cuz that will always help
crazy you they shoulda given us Jerry
Springer mother-daughter boxing ring
matches soon as she turns 18 i'ma just
punch the [ __ ] out of my kid for
everything that she's done oh yeah just
for fun I wanna see a lot of use that's
a lot of ratings absolutely as soon as
your daughter turns 18 so like as soon
as your daughter turns 18 on the show
right the [ __ ] curtains go up in a
boxing ring shows up and then you start
putting on gloves and [ __ ] and a lot are
let's do it [ __ ]
I'd be threatening her every day when
she was 17 and she gave me problems I'm
gonna take you on Jerry
just wait wait till you're 18 I'm gonna
take you damn you know how kids like
they want parents want their kids to
like grow and be tall and like strong
and stuff I'm like [ __ ] no ma'am
I'm gonna keep you frail and weak ass
[ __ ] you up barely feed your ass oh my
god
watch they still [ __ ] me up - they're
like four foot - did you Brendan
no what they didn't even smack you not
they play mental games like [ __ ] that
mental game to teach me a lesson of like
importance of money because I was like
it's just it's just a few dollars my mom
I took a ball from from the kitchen
through it in front of me is like all
right if you think it's so easy to make
money go outside and beg for money if
you don't feel like working
imagine you kill it though you come back
with like three four hundred dollars
you're like all right now what mom what
are you scared yeah I mean yeah I
eventually I was like all right these
guys they're just joking around she gave
you what Bolin told you to go outside
and beg for money
yeah it's a big [ __ ] to teach me the
importance of money such a passion of
shoot like she would always threaten me
go outside repent for money I died and I
grabbed the ball before I reach the
front door that's why bug Brandon is
probably not a violent person Oh cuz he
didn't get me yeah
could be could be you're a pretty chill
guy yeah I have to learn to like think
and calm down you know I mean like not
react but my kid pissing me off and like
to the point where I feel like hitting
him key word is hit him yes is him it's
probably so easy to [ __ ] smack a boy
yeah versus acting up oh yeah every like
a daughter it'll be hard for me to smack
my son yeah is that why moms
spank them the daughters and then the
dad spank that the boys maybe hmm I got
it from both though I'll slap them both
damn it's like funny we're talking about
our future kids like we're gonna beat
the [ __ ] out like we already have this
hate for them but like two things but
also that like if we're ready to slap
our kids that anger will be multiplied
times three if somebody else did
something else to our kids we love our
so much that we just gotta slap them you
know you know what I don't even hit my
ducks I don't think I might have my kids
I can't even hit my dogs even if they're
being bad
well you can't hit you can't get dogs
because that like people love dogs more
than people because dogs don't talk
they can't make you mad they're always
happy yeah they can't speak dogs could
talk you might slap his ass that's true
and dogs they don't [ __ ] up ever on
purpose mm-hmm but kids they can
purposely go against what the [ __ ] you
want dude imagine if cats could talk 40%
of people would not [ __ ] like him
yeah